it can be hard be difficult job and I
love my job don't get me wrong but it
can be hard to present the day's complex
news stories in a way that's easy to
understand and at the same time
entertaining that's the challenge of
this gig and it's challenge for shows
like ours day in day out like the big
story right now about the political
fight over the deferred action for
childhood arrivals program or daca okay
now if I try to explain the nuances of
this important story be pretty dull
right so here's what we did we invited a
group that specializes in making the
news fun and exciting
here to explain daca it's the jump City
jumpers
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah welcome to the show jump city
jumpers thanks Conan we came here
tonight to do two things discuss the
comprehensive legislative history of the
DREAM Act and jump let's go see your
bruise okay
the DREAM Act was first introduced in
2001 by Stander's Orrin Hatch and Maria
Cantwell it was designed to create a
legal path to citizenship for thousands
of young immigrants after the bill
failed to pass legislation President
Obama ordered daca which was intended to
postpone deportation for these so-called
dreamers that's the history of death
yeah okay I'm just curious you guys that
was very good of you guys you guys doing
okay yeah okay this is a great overview
but I'm sure our audience would love to
know more about who those dreamers are
more more detail no problem let's let's
jump jump okay so here's how the
dreamers breakdown statistically as you
can see most are young in fact 36.7% of
them are between the ages of 21 and 25
the majority of the 689 thousand active
dr. participants are from Latin
countries like Mexico and El Salvador
whew there it is
you guys alright you seem you seem just
a little bit tired you sure you're okay
yeah we're we're jumped astok yeah okay
jumps okay jumps yeah so doc has been a
big political football lately I'm sure
we'd love to hear more about that hmm I
don't think so yeah no no I know my
audience and I think we all want
we go
you mother all right
yeah sure
so Jack in protecting change radically
on steps half half of 2017 wait Tom find
out there anything imperfect
meanwhile Democrats argue that the
participants represent a very small
percentage of undocumented immigrants so
like this hand represents total
undocumented immigrants then the test
test tube is this either the people
protected by doctor that's him
Democrat clean daca Republicans Oh wall
drug [ __ ] that's pretty much it
[Applause]
jump city jumpers everybody
you